it's one of my all-time favorite games
that holds a very special place in my
heart I remember being a young sean
playing this game on dreamcast when it
first came out and just being blown away
but like the general openness of it
because I had never played anything
quite like this before it's compared to
open world games these days of like a
grand theft auto Cheryl yeah sounds
impressed it's very different there are
a lot of walls there are a lot of
loading screens those damn walls this I
think is actually the first time that
i'm replaying it since i first played
the game way back when so I'm almost
scared how it might shatter the
illusions of this being some wonderful
game that's aged incredibly well you
should be scared Sean because I placed
on this last night and it has not aged
that one does not age that well but talk
to these kids yeah Oh duo have know any
Chinese people this is like one of those
things that I really loved about the
game when it first came out is it felt
like exploring a small little Japanese
city and I say that having never been to
Japan when I first played this game
right just like I don't the scope of the
things like all the little details that
you could do like going to soda machines
going to capsule machines yeah just felt
it felt really interesting at the time
and I'm just slugging this jet Cola you
know I wasn't gonna die oh oh that's
delicious so tasty take care your
knuckles dude boy you know like his tush
two knuckles oh yeah look at this all
right I'm gonna try one more okay sweet
i'll add it to my collection maybe i
should get another yes yeah that's good
i definitely feel the eviction I've got
10,000 yen these are only a hundred
janna pop and we've got 55 55 minutes to
spend just dumping yen into this capsule
that is pretty cool okay all right I
should try again no no no rio rio you
have to avenge your father's day [ __ ]
uh-huh Tom saw Landy and suggested I
seek information from Chinese people Oh
No hey how's the key you think you can
bump into me know either but enjoy ya
jerk apologized a little ji-sun not
millionaires big aboagye to you I don't
have time for this get lost see you
mystery the boss what I press the button
damn you da ya hate it its bunch of
dicks what do you know about Chinese
people hook up the time to play your
little games I know quick time events so
you guys better just slow your roll oh
these girls are real jerks Hey ladies
got a minute you girls like party looks
good that's harsh what just cuz your
friend here is pooping doesn't mean I
can't talk to you come on scuze me quit
pokin for is it whoa you are did you see
I'm pooping here okay see I'm pooping
come on you get away from me i'm pooping
can't a girl pinched one off the beasts
Oh gross but yes she should be able to
do that in peace no no lapis I've been
expecting you no no okay no hell yeah
why don't you tell him about the three
blades yeah towels on the three blades
three blades three bleh it's
blaze it literally refers to three
different three different trades the
barber the tailor and the cook they all
use bladed tools true the barber uses
always yes okay Taylor uses scissors yep
and cook use his knives are you one of
the three blades terribly sorry but I've
been too tired lately I'm not in the
mecca has really low serotonin levels oh
oh yeah I didn't know I'm okay longwall
how's business not his eyes are so
intense I have you Sokka helping me out
that's one thing you guys need to pay
attention to look at the intensity of
Rio's eyes relative to the intensity of
everybody else because his eyes are like
he's been doing about me too I like a
I'm a ziplock baggie full of Cu cocaine
where as everybody else looks like they
haven't been doing that he is turned on
his he's real keyed up my buddy Tom hey
Rio hide y'all did you come up with
anything about the men in black suits
nope no crew and so on I see isn't that
great under to see I can't hope you are
done I'm looking for Chinese people have
you guys met Chinese people you look
busy on the contrary let me bother you
real quick I have nothing to live for
his Hobbes ah Surya he's a Taser tough
competitor God wake up dude people talk
so slow I'm disappointed that every time
you run by a machine you're not getting
a soda thank you all right now when I
drink this soda I want you to pay
attention to the way he like had squints
one I really awkwardly as if he's well
you know just use your imagination there
all right here it comes watch the face
watch the face this is critical
it is here it is Oh more more get to me
oh you like frowns a bit before smiling
idea yeah hurts you know it hurts him a
little bit but he loves it too much not
to oh hey Tom yo no I'm talking my buddy
Tom oh hello your way cool in the Tom
try again when you get a bit older what
damn wow she's only into old I think
that was a russian prostitute Bose ride
up here turn right at the corner by the
arcade I see Jesus tongue tongue down a
little bit did you know that the proud
lead of these professions we're also
Imperial bodyguard I was just so helpful
just tell me who killed my dad so I no
murderer damn nice sailors I'll look for
sailors huh much open my eyes oh well
you don't say ok excuse me sir you know
where I can find a little sailor ok ooh
do you want I have something to ask you
whoa this guy's so butthurt about the
time I kicked his ass you know anywhere
around here where sailors hang out don't
do both yeah I see excuse me I guess you
wouldn't then would you got a minute
yeah if you want directions ask somebody
else dude hold his face she said she had
a minute oh yeah yeah I got time but if
you want direction [ __ ] off hey this
guy's pretty cool where the sailors hang
out around here they hang around
everywhere at nighttime the hell is that
me teeth but yeah wait is that one tooth
hey you gonna start a fight with them oh
yeah hey I'm not like you oh we would
see you in a real looks like you're
getting excited about it but who
wouldn't get excited about just hanging
out with some sailors knocking back a
few maybe see where it goes from there
which bar do they hang out at I don't
know bro oh look Tommy Brenton off here
later and thus we learn Tom's shameful
secret which is road which is that he
has no money to his name you say sailors
but you don't mean just any sale wink
right tried to mjq jazz bar or heart
beats barn all these people just
drinking by themselves at their one
person tables this guy's casting spells
this guy is a trance keep talking
himself this guy has been dead for weeks
this bar sad he keeps ordering drinks
somehow [ __ ] you Tom look Utah under the
sea I never sleep everything's better
downwards wetta i'm so broke take it
from me Space Harrier 100 Deanna game am
I doing here uh you are shooting
everything engine muster the courage and
ability to shoot
anybody just tuning in now we're still
playing Shenmue it's just we're in the
arcade that lets you play classic sega
games this is hang on a game that uses
uki made right I believe he was involved
in salt no he didn't make it with his
own bare hands but that you mean literal
bear yes yeah he was involved the
creation of hang on in space harrier i'm
gonna find some sailors yeah we got ten
minutes to find some sailors and you
better believe who we're gonna find some
sailors what I skin to be nine o'clock
Tom just uh appears as if an apparition
sent from the heavens got a minute oh
this lady if you want to be asked
somebody you know if she had taken the
time just to tell you where to go at
this point she would have shoot him
avoided these guys oh yeah yeah you're
not gonna stop what what do you know
anywhere that sailors hang out I don't
know off their sailors I see this town
is just filled with helpful people
people are all terrible let's see uh
yeah what the hell is this what the hell
is what's going on here guys we're live
what you guys scanner up the street
we're just gonna interrupt our stream
just to do your lobby promo oh okay all
right no the time that's fine that's
fine that's fine we understand we
understand it's not like we're live on
the internet or it's already looking for
sailors on yeah we're not like just
constantly looking for sailors and
shenmue or anything nobody's here nobody
was here I think they wanted our sailors
Danny O'Dwyer just just burst into the
studio right now to shoot a promo for
the lobby classic o'dwyer classic Dani
Eva Jeffrey I have a Jeffrey look at
this who needs some sailors yeah you
want some sailors to come get some of
this oh yeah look at these sailors with
a real bunch of sailors what a bunch of
sailors oh yeah as far as classy as [ __ ]
are you guys say loose
could be could be kid how about a game
of lucky hat game you sink the ball in
one shot you win and I'll answer your
questions all right and then some other
stuff with and you got answers my
questions you're all just get right the
shower right try your luck whoa hit
through that just goes so vertically
this looks good wait wait wait wait
great success unbelievable man the deal
was I make the shot and you tell me what
I want to know now who's the Sailor
sailors nah we're base workers Oh
mangers drinketh the heartbeats ah dude
you're constantly get the runner in our
hey let's bed again come on not if
you're not a sailor yeah I only mess
with sailors got a minute I have
something to do now let's talk later you
have nothing to do you're standing out
out find this bar close your mouth and
you're just like huddling uh oh look at
these guys they're probably sailors you
guys sailors or zombies I can't really
guys know where I can find something dad
on my way
I'm a sailor who do you think those guys
are sailors or were they trying to
protect the sailors from Rio they're
trying to protect there's a package soon
oh yeah these are our sailors you here
cuz everybody knows that you don't let
Rio around those sailors whoa look at
this stale a bar yeah what's up sailors
you guys like the sale Mariano all milks
perfect for a school how did he already
have that ready did he just have like
milks behind the bar ready just plop
down and I'm looking for some milk jugs
with Chinese ships it's funny Oh what
kind of TV detective or something back
off what are you some kind of sailor or
something oh no you get deck you get
bubble stupid
who's a sailor now that's enough you put
on quite a show boy